lissa mitchellson boated to leave the EU
the next day the flowers she buys in
from Europe were 20% more expensive but
she hasn't regretted her decision I
think that it's a positive move forward
and whilst a lot of people you know are
very very negative about it it's
happened now and we need to embrace it
as Britain made its brexit official
remain as in Sunderland city center
stage to protest isn't this rather like
going to the bar or during a pipe when
the landlord sort of rung the bell for
time no not at all I mean nobody seems
to know least of all the government
whether article 50 is reversible it will
send a message to tourism a that
whatever she says that 60 million people
are behind her that is not the case they
may well be hoping that brexit simply
doesn't happen for whatever reason but
it is unlikely the bigger questions will
be about how this region copes outside
of Europe thousands of people still rely
on manufacturing in the Northeast
Theresa May put the individual at the
centre of her letter to Europe saying
negotiations should put the citizen
first
this company in County Durham exports
mainly to Europe workers here say
they're encouraged by the Prime
Minister's stance I think it's
absolutely right and I think it is
exactly how we should approach the
negotiations with Europe I want to raise
a mere - to listen to the people and and
and and think about the people of this
country I think that um here in the UK
we've seen a lot of campaigning by the
politicians the European man in the
street will have seen the same from
their politicians and at the end of the
day now the time is right to get down to
it many here saw brexit as a chance for
change but no one really knows yet if
that change will be for the better
Nick Martin Sky News Sunderland